you know there are some things in
wrestling where I kind of like well I
can tell you whether they're fake
wrestling always okay I mean that's not
I mean no I don't mind they're yelling
at each other so that's what they're
doing no it is another word for that as
nothing well Brian would someone call
the great works of Shakespeare nothing
well now it would someone called she
looks forward to winning at all and my
friend said but it's a play so hard to
play that's not a play so how do you win
at all yeah although she looks adorable
there I think she's just looking really
really cute um I'll tell you this right
now you know she'll probably win
whatever the heck her first matches but
then what they do she got to give it
back you know what I mean really she
well she's got a she's got a give back
they Kate that's wrong
no I'm saying she's got to like give
back the the victory now you know those
acts and that's how people you stay
interested they go who you know money
her even though you asked me for money
sometimes I've never asked you for money
sir please no money please if you take
that back well you have them you have
not to spread rumors but no I would
never you have a drug problem
I do have a [ __ ] heavy drug yeah so
let me ask you this that's why you're
wearing dentures right now but let me
ask you this Oh check this out Oh God
here's my Shane McKellen ah in the
gallon Shane MacGowan Shane MacGowan
kind of money you think she's making for
this [ __ ] do I know what the [ __ ] what I
know how much they make I don't know a
few hundred K or a million bucks I don't
[ __ ] know a lot of money look at how
many people who slaughter the way she's
Ronda Rousey alright she's got a t-shirt
on like a hot rod Rowdy Roddy Piper she
looks if it says hot Ronda she's a cutie
pie I love her she's a cutie pie they're
all cutie pies and now you've never been
to a wrestling event no I read and also
I when you go or when you go and you sit
up close it's so you see how the how
they could so easily get hurt
which I would follow up with if I were
Bryan Callen for nothing and it's so
easy for them to get hurt and like the
the gal on the right in the last picture
there mmm this that's a little girl
that's a little girls little yeah tiny
thing she's tired I remember going like
a thing and you see these these you know
women going all
because it's a big event and you just
like you're doing a lot of yeah and I
did the same thing I remember when we
went and when we watched Brendan fight
in Vancouver and i sat there at cage
side going yeah you know what well I'm
trying to say I said and they all say
that the injury rate is crazy like it's
it is not easy
you got to be an athlete to be in the
you also have to know you also have to
have a dance partner knows what they're
doing or else someone's gonna get hurt
people get hurt
bottom line is Brian yeah I want to
speak to this as far as wrestling fans
yourself and to me and mixed martial
arts all right you know our dear pal
Brendan in the middle of a I train is
about literally life life and death so
condescending okay I said I trained you
can't let me finish what I'm saying
don't shush me it's so obnoxious I meant
if you say anything else I'm not saying
anything all I said was in passing I
trained as well don't hold on let me
finish okay let me feel this you know
cuz I can hear it even though don't talk
if you tie I can do my podcast okay all
I said was I trained you see let me
finish what I'm saying all right but
don't coach okay don't talk fine
I trained quiet right now all right
let me finish okay here's something
you're talking I'm trying to finish all
right now I I have the same you talking
still you are not a lot don't ya listen
I have the same reaction whether it's
Ronda Rousey in a you know in a leather
coat yeah and a little Alexa bliss over
there slamming each other around and
doing their dance right sure as I do
to Brendan in a life-and-death battle
you know in a real fight right real
fight in the cage UFC I mean and to even
to be that close to it man oh man it's
that's a different puts a different
paint job on things let me tell you
and it's the exact same reaction for me
why is that why cuz I had Shh I told you
to shut the [ __ ] up because I have I
have what's called an imagination okay
now when you have an imagination
yeah I have an imagination too you know
a lot of people watch mixed martial arts
or combat sports like this you know
whether it's boxing kickboxing they cut
out the calendar you know I'm Alan dough
is right
nope just wits when a guy's one of 51
year old guy sits in the middle of a mat
tries to get hard not just I've never
done that dude really never sat in the
middle of a mat and tug my putt
especially challenged oh you know what I
would love to see you do what I would
love you I would love to see you walk
out in front of a small group of paint a
small paying audience yeah you know in
Cambodia or something why in a ring when
they're making you know they got food
running around they got people serving
food and they're fat and you know how
they have like yeah they got bets going
and there's just like you know music
fight before that a bit of talk to
animals to different animals to roosters
yeah every now Mena maybe three roosters
or just one dog and two wild dogs yeah
that would be good yeah anything really
a ferret versus a jellyfish some weird
[ __ ] sure that stuff yeah and then the
main event Brian you come out in really
short Muay Thai shorts yeah right and
then you whip them off put that award
down sit on it get it up your ass try to
get hard in the middle of the [ __ ]
room this is [ __ ] [ __ ] you think I
have [ __ ] you think you are I'm not that
guy I'd pay pay-per-view money for give
a [ __ ] what you'd pay I would never do
that I would love to see walking out in
Cambodia after all these animals have
been fighting yeah and I'm not walking
out there 51 yeah
pulling down my super really short
shorts my time and then sitting on that
this thing's just a war that says best
woman I'm not sitting on that [ __ ]
yeah and getting your brown balloon not
all around that and sitting on it you
really brought this podcast down until I
was up into your large intestine I'm not
doing that Shh a bigger award I'll get
you out to tell you what well I'll get
you a full Tower now you know from I'm
gonna get you a bunch of every time I'm
in an airport I'm gonna get you
something that we can put up your ass
well you try to get your flaccid fish
dick hard in front of people eating you
know don't call it flashing and what's
the other thing larb that's in Laura
that's all ty you're being you're
assuming that I find it more offensive
that you're assuming that Cambodian
cuisine is the same as Thai cuisine
never okay so name one Cambodia jet car
what's your favorite what's your
favorite Cambodian dish you're too
ignorant to even know what it is I can
tell you what it is because I've spent
time in that part of the world and I
have great deal respect for for all
different kinds of essentially cuisine
you know what mine is what mung bean
black bean and you can stop right there
because mung bean belongs to to Vietnam
okay of the to the Hmong people no okay
that was so easy and you don't animation
[ __ ] no black beans because that
belongs to make equal so at the end of
the day you're gonna waiting to and I
thought it very offensive uh one of my
favorite Cambodian dishes yeah go ahead
the Cambodian BLT that what is that
though what's in it it's got you're
making it up see it alright you're
already pausing it's got goat bacon no
goat there and there's no coke bacon you
can't make bacon out of go goddamnit
River lettuce there's zero okay wait a
minute
River lettuce River leans you mean the
lily they kind of like the vegetation
that sort of floats on the top of the
river yo it spoken like a man who's been
to Cambodia finally yeah but they don't
think you can eat those that's that's
giant lily pads yeah and then and then
you know just your basic hothouse tomato
on toast
well there's no 20 goes in that's in the
new world so that doesn't belong to
Cambodia so what
what do you mean Tomatoes far as
Tomatoes like tomatoes the little ones
that grow on the ground some nice vine
tomatoes same as you get at Ralph's or
Cambodia not in Cambodia I don't think
so oh I guess I guess the last time I
was in Cambodia in a restaurant eating a
Cambodian BLT watching you get your
puckered [ __ ] down my life your dick
hard
no I must have just been hallucinating
yeah yeah sure brings me back to my
point I can watch you know some mixed
martial arts happen I can watch some
wrestling or you ever you want to call
it happen and it's just it's all an
enchantment of the mind for me because I
have what's called an imagination serves
me well so I am fan of wrestling still I
like their colorful outfits and
personalities I like it when they say
I'm gonna win no I'm gonna win and then
you watch it and then Vince McMahon has
decided who's gonna win and then you
okay then you see that so it's fixed the
old train is basically good the way God
it kind of has already decided your
destiny and you can do everything you
want you know at the end of the day
you're still gonna burn the lake of fire
if your Will Sasso right well you're off
you're even more go to the next believe
it or the next if I don't get out of
here so I can get out of I gotta get the
[ __ ] right back to the airport and
fly you know you've made me so sick I'm
gonna fly back to Canada Wow what's
Canadians love you because you're
Canadian
I'm also America not really us right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]